منتدى الاقتصاد العالمي في بلده
دابوسويسريه من اشهر المؤتمرات في العالم
متى بدا لماذا هو مهم من يشارك فيه وماذا
يناقش انا لارا حبيب تابعوني في هذه
التغطيه الخاصه من دافوس من اعلى بلده
اوروبيه فكره دافوس بدات في العام 1971 من
بروفيسور سويسري اسمه كلاو شواب دعا الى
اجتماع لطرح نظريته التي تدعى
اساسها ان الشركات يجب ان تخدم ليس فقط
مصلحه ملاك او المساهمين بل يجب ان تراعي
مصلحه الموظفين والموردين والبيئه
والمجتمع الذي تعمل فيه منذ ذلك الحين
اصبحت راسماليه اصحاب المصلحه او
السيكودوريس هي المبدا التوجيهي للمنتدى
من ياتي الى دافوس حوالي 2500 شخص من
رؤساء تنفيذيين لكبرى الشركات رؤساء
حكومات وزراء ممثلين منظمات دوليه مجتمع
المدني بالطبع اعلاميين مثل انا وفريق
العربيه يطلق عليهم اسم رجال دافوس دافوس
8 ينتقدهم البعض انهم النخبه الغنيه التي
ليس لها بالواقع الصعب يلي عم بناقشه على
فكره اليوم عم نتحدث انه اكثر من 40 في
المئه من المتحدثين هم من النساء هل في
قرارات مهمه بيتخذها المنتدى ما في قرارات
ملزمه ولكن الحوار بيعطي الحكومات والدول
الافكار والمساعده على اتخاذ قراراتها
الاقتصاديه والسياسيه وقد كان المنتدى في
قلب العديد من الاحداث العالميه مثلا في
العام
1998 فكره مجموعه العشرين بدات بالعام
1989 اجتمع رئيس وزرع المانيا الشرقيه
ومستشار المانيا الغربيه بمنتدى دافوس
لمناقشه الاتحاد و بعام 2000 مبادره
تالقاحات العالميه انطلقت من دابوس وغيرها
ما هي المواضيع التي يناقشها المنتدى
يعتبر المنتدى من اكبر الداعمين لفكره
العولمه عبر مرور السنين كما يناقش دائما
مواضيع مرتبطه بتغيير المناخي والشمول
والتنوع بالاضافه الى التطورات المهمه على
الساحه العالميه وفي ظل اتراجع الكبير
للشعبيه العولمه في السنوات الاخيره مع
تنام الحركات الشعبويه والاجراءات
الحمائيه والانقسامات السياسيه يعتقد
المنتدى هذا العام تحت عنوان التعاون في
عالم مجزاء فهل سينجح المؤتمر باحياء
العولمه التي تعلم نادى بها